a trans activist is calling on his
fellow
trans identifying people
to break the law increasingly as the
governors come in and they say no more
transiting the kids no more puberty
blockers for kids no more sex change
procedures for kids
there are a number of transsexuals trans
identifying people
who say we've got to break the law
pay attention to the news lately and my
life has gone really great but
unfortunately there's a lot of people
trans people trans youth who are really
suffering right now and need our support
like this bill in Mississippi is
absolutely appalling to me the fact that
the government is overstepping it's
about like the government does not have
any right to legislate your gender
identity so if you're trans youth if
you're a trans adult don't need
transition don't hide don't be done be
as out there and as bold as you possibly
can be without necessarily jeopardizing
your own safety I'm not saying you
should do
be safe but like we need to stand up and
tell the government what for because
this is absolutely uh don't
de-transition if you're a medical
provider do everything you can to not
obey the laws these are unjust laws they
have no right to be existing and the
moral thing to do is to break them in
whatever way possible like I'm there's
parts of me that want to do things that
I can't say on here to people that are
doing this to people and it really makes
me so sad and this is the only thing
that I hate in life is opposing
suffering onto other people who don't
deserve it because I know what that
feels like so I'm sorry for the late
night rambling ranting video and I know
I try to make a lot of positive
uplifting on here but like it does have
to be addressed and there's a I tagged
um content creators in here go sign the
petition in Josh's bio uh go follow them
too for gay news and stand up do
whatever it takes March in the streets
okay you got the picture so what what
this guy is calling for is civil
disobedience against what he says are
unjust laws now I know people are going
to have an emotional reaction to this
immediately when you hear this
demented individual say that we need to
make sure that doctors violate the laws
so that they can go in and pump your
kids full of poison and chop their
genitals off I know that is gonna is
going to impel people to have a visceral
reaction and say bro
we're going to chase you out of town on
a rail or we're gonna lock you up in
prison or in a mental institution or
something like that and I get all of
that and
that that could be a discussion for a
later time
what we should deal with though is his
claim he's saying these laws that say
that you can't chop off kids genitals
they're unjust because
men can secretly be women or something
and that's my view and that's why we
need to stand up against those laws okay
if people stand up against those laws if
people do what this guy is saying
that is very sad for them because
they're mistaken about what Justice is
and they're mistaken about what human
nature is and it would be good to
correct these people and not allow these
pathologies to spread so much that we're
seeing these sorts of videos but if they
do that then we need to give them what
they ask for
if they do they say we're going to break
the law consequences come what may we
need to throw them into prison and
that's going to be the next step signing
the legislation is really really great
and it's good stuff for the Republican
Governors who have done and the
legislators who've done that but now
when people break the laws when they
when they
pedal porn to kids in elementary schools
when they trans the children we we're
getting reports that in Texas Children's
Hospital
some of these quacks perform sex change
procedures on kids as young as 11. okay
when these people break the law we need
to throw the book at them we are now
living in a system in which if you're a
good American Marine who has served your
country you're a good Patriot and you
protect people from a career violent
criminal with dozens and dozens of
arrests including for assault and you
protect them from a guy who's saying I'm
going to kill an F I'm gonna kill I
don't care I'm prepared to die you're
going to go to prison they're going to
throw the book at you but if you chop
off kids genitals you're you're not even
going to get a slap on the wrist okay
we're living in that system right now
and we need to
flip that situation we need to live in a
system that does not punish people for
doing good things but encourages them to
do good things we need to live in a
system that punishes people for doing
bad things very very bad things in this
case right now go to puretalk.com
Knowles do you remember the last time
you got a free phone started out feeling
great and then came the Hefty activation
fees the four-line requirements and of
course that binding contract Pure Talk
is giving you a free 5G Samsung Galaxy
phone without the feeling that you've
been duped when you switch to Pure talks
unlimited talk and text data plan that
comes with a mobile hotspot you will get
a 5G Samsung Galaxy for free that's
right unlimited everything at a fraction
of the price of Verizon ATT or T-Mobile
here's the thing you'll be on America's
Most Dependable 5G network not just a
similar network but the very same one
how do I know because I'm a customer
make the switch to Pure Talk the cell
phone Wireless company I am proud to
stand behind because they provide a
phenomenal product and they're proud to
stand behind our mission at the daily
wire pure talks us-based customer
service team helps make the switch in as
little as 10 minutes and you can even
keep your phone number go to
puretalk.com Knowles kwles for your free
Samsung Galaxy when you sign up for
unlimited talk text and unlimited data
that is puretalk.com Knowles Pure Talk
Wireless for Americans by Americans you
know the Jordan Neely killing on the
subway which is being called a murder by
all the libs and which is being called
heroic self-defense and the protection
of a community by conservatives so which
is it did this Marine did he go out
there because he's probably racist you
know all these guys they're racist dude
go out there because you just want to
kill a poor innocent man who he just
wanted to moonwalk on the Subways
basically Michael Jackson but better
than Michael Jackson because he didn't
do the kids stuff
or was this guy protecting the subway
train from a career criminal who'd been
picked up at least 42 times who had
assaulted people who had given a
60-something-year-old woman a black eye
well according to an eyewitness
it's the latter
eyewitness says I'm sitting on a train
reading my book and all of a sudden I
hear someone spewing this rhetoric he
said I don't care if I have to kill an F
I will I'll go to jail I'll take a
bullet
so not only threatening violence on
people saying I don't care
I don't care if I have to kill somebody
I'm not only going to be violent I'm
going to kill somebody
said everyone on the train was scared
for our lives
nearly had 42 prior arrests and an
active warrant just a couple years ago
Neely attacked a 67 year old woman gave
her a black eye and a broken nose and
then this hero
Marine comes in
and he
takes the guy down and the guy should be
given a key to the city and the guy
should be given an award and instead
they're going to try to throw him in
prison
what we can see from this is that
disfavored groups are judged on a curve
okay obviously if the races were
reversed here you wouldn't hear about it
it'd be totally fine no big deal
whatsoever but that's not what's
happening
what's happening is because this guy is
white because he was in the military
because the the career criminal who was
killed is black this guy is going to
have to be so buttoned up and perfect
you're going to have to have
eyewitnesses going even further than
this woman you're going to have to and I
hope this is what happened for this poor
Marine sake I hope that this guy this
Neely was so explicit in what he was
obviously likely to do on the subway I
will kill people if I am not taken down
by a marine right now and choked on the
ground I really hope that is the case
because in our unjust system
this Marine who this is an open and shut
Common Sense case in our unjust system
this guy
is going to have to be perfectly
buttoned up or he is going to get the
book thrown at him
boy what a clip that was huh if you want
to get more of them as well as the long
interviews and the full show and all the
different games you gotta ring that Bell
subscribe to the Michael Knowles YouTube
channel